après plusieurs cas de covile 19 parmi
les accusés le procès des attentats de
janvier 2015 a repris l'événement est
intégralement filmé une rareté en france
car depuis la loi sur la liberté de la
presse en 1881 enregistré une audience
est interdit pourtant 1954 un procès
attire les journalistes du monde entier
celui de gaston dominici qui vient de
voir son activité décuplée par
l'ouverture du procès dominici l'homme
est accusé d'avoir tué trois personnes à
lurs en provence en dépit de la loi
le procès est filmé par des journalistes
conséquence de cette pagaille médiatique
une loi est votée en urgence le 6
décembre 1954 renforçant celle de 1881
dans les salles d'audience caméras et
micros sont formellement interdits mais
en 1983 un événement relance le débat
celui de l'arrestation de l'ancien nazi
klaus barbie robert badinter alors
ministre de la justice ouvre la voie à
une captation de certains procès dits
historiques les archives judiciaires
sont vides parce que l'on sait pas assez
soucié de voir comment l'on pouvait
réussir à conserver des documents
sonores ou visuelles suffisant
c'est fait le 11 juillet 1985 avec la
promulgation de la loi badinter en 1987
des caméras fixes enregistre le procès
de klaus barbie à lyon en intégralité
il y a toute la presse mondiale réunis
dans cette salle pour juger un dossier
qui dépasse de loin le cadre générale
ordinaire de ce qui se jugent dans la
cour d'assises de lyon
trois ans plus tard en 1990
un autre procès est filmé et celui de
sergio young un bijoutier accusé d'avoir
blessé un cambrioleur mais le procès
n'est pas historique
aucune autorisation n'a été délivrée
pourtant le président du tribunal a bien
autorisé deux équipes de télévision à
capter les débats voulais que les gens
sachent qu est ce qu on peut faire
qu'est-ce qu'on ne peut pas faire quand
on peut dire qu'il ya les victimes
pensent quand il n'ya pas légitimement
et j'ai pensé qu'en donnant cette
publicité aux débats que cette audience
éclairerait le public par le canal des
médias
verdict serge lyon d'état qui tu es mais
le débat sur la captation de tous les
procès est lancé
quinze ans plus tard en 2005 un rapport
est remis au garde des sceaux dominique
perben
le texte se prononce pour une levée de
l'interdiction mais sous certaines
conditions
les audiences seraient enregistrés
intégralement et diffuser le plus
largement possible après la décision du
tribunal
enfin la protection des personnes
participant aux audiences rassure aucune
suite n'a été donnée à ce rapport
aujourd'hui les procès historiques sont
toujours les seuls à pouvoir être filmé
celui des attentats de janvier 2015 et
le 14e à être enregistrés il sera
conservé aux archives nationales est
consultable par les chercheurs et le
grand public
[Musique]